[Music]
[Applause]
let's bring in Michael Vic who joins us
now how do you think you would do in
that uh nil World there
Mike morning Dan that's that's a great
segue into this
interview um it it really uh got my got
my brain racing thinking about it um
yeah I would have been uh one of the top
you know top guys to get paid from n um
hands
down north of a
million that would starting
salary what's that that would have been
your starting uh negotiating point is a
million youd be worth a lot more than a
million dollars yeah I think um hey look
I was about to come back to
school just just to be with my teammates
because I miss them so much so I can
only imagine if $100,000 or $500,000 was
at my discretion through nil oh I would
have came back to school for I would
have definitely gave Virginia Tech a
discount for
sure do you remember you're I think what
five years younger than alen Iverson is
that five years yeah four years younger
okay do you remember him playing
football in the Virginia Beach area
because he was a pretty good quarterback
by all accounts yeah I do I remember uh
not not so vividly because he was a
little older I remember him going
against uh my cousin Aon Brooks um I
think eron's sophomore year because I
don't think Allan played his junior year
and Senior year so I caught him early
but I really wasn't paying attention to
him as much as I was paying attention to
eron but I did see that he had the
potential to become a good football
player really good football player if
that's what he wanted you think he could
have played in the
NFL
yes I do think he could have played in
NFL UM quarterback I don't know it
depends on you know how committed he
would have been but you know if he's a
point guard you know same
responsibilities um but you know
probably in his time he might have been
a little bit before his time he might
have got put he might have got switched
to a different position because he was
so athletic and um but if he would have
stayed at the quarterback position I
think he would have had a chance at
playing in the NFL if he would have you
know took it serious so Mich Vic joining
us four-time Pro Bowl number one overall
pick by the Falcons and Fox NFL analyst
recently named to Madden's 25th
anniversary team how would you compare
your running style to Barry
Sanders uh the exact same running style
Barry was one of the guys I adaliz
growing up uh I don't think I missed the
Thanksgiving uh when it was Detroit and
Green Bay playing uh on National
Television as long as I was able to you
know turn that dial on my TV and get the
TV to come in with a clear picture
growing
up you know sometimes you had cable
sometimes you didn't but you know for
the most part it was always on regular
TV and I was able to catch Barry and
analyze him so you know brry and and
Walter Payton was my two favorite
Runners of all time and so I wanted to
be a running back I actually started out
as a running back but uh like could you
have been an NFL running back in your
mind like in every down back yeah for
sure I think I you know I had the
stature for it um being 6 feet 215
pounds I'd have been uh considered a big
back um but explosive I think my biggest
challenge would have been taking on
linebackers uh you know and have it to
protect because you know that that
becomes Paramount uh as as a running
back as especially as you come in Young
And as you mature um it's a I put a lot
of responsibilities on the guys that I
played with war done uh lesea McCoy in
terms of you know um the passing game
and understanding protections because if
a running back don't know who to block
you'll get hit every down so uh I think
you know learning that part of it would
have been a challenge but I think I
would have been able to be a really good
running back if ID have stuck
to who was the most talented quarterback
of all
time
um I would say the most
talented uh you know I'm always put PA
Manning at the top of the list because
Payton was just uh phenomenal um and you
know even when you're talking about
athletes you know pton might not have
moved around but the way he threw the
football with accuracy I think you know
only certain guys can do that only a
handful of guys came through that that
could make the throws and you know to
have the competence that he had at the
quarterback position um but I think most
athletic and you know when you bottle
everybody you know you think about
everybody's talents I think you you
gotta go with Charlie Ward I just seen a
legend of Charlie Ward a couple days ago
and I just watching him um even though
he was a little small in stature he he
played really big and and so I think the
things that he was able to do um I think
makes him one of the most gifted
quarterback that ever lineup behind
center next to me of course of course I
might put Randle Cunningham in there as
far as Talent yeah I put Randle in there
but I mean I would have to put myself at
the top of that list and there's been
some great quarterbacks uh to come and
go and don't get me wrong these guys
were extremely talented but um you know
like I said I played running
back that was merged into becoming a you
know quarterback you know Steve Young
was my favorite quarterback growing up
and Barry Sanders was one of my favorite
running back so you Clos your eyes and
you merg that together and picture that
behind the center you get me
and you know I was able to put that on
display so I would say I would put me in
at the top of that list as well okay but
then looking back on that most talented
quarterback of all time but you didn't
get everything that you needed to get
like if there was one thing that you go
if I only would have done
that yeah I would have gotten the most
out of my
potential I think if if I would have
um you know took the hus of you know
calling my own plays or just be being
ahead of you know especially early in my
career I you know when I think back on
my career I I look and feel like you
know there were times where I could have
helped my coordinator out even more you
know I think if I would have spent more
time on Tuesdays when the coaches are
game planning and putting it all
together and trying to figure out how to
beat the opponent and what it's going to
take for our guys to be successful
versus you know the opposition that week
if I would have spend a little time on
Tuesdays with the coaches and I've heard
stories about other quarterbacks doing
this Drew Brees and John Elway and Dan
Reeves told me John used to come in on
Tuesdays and just kind of sit in and
just listen to the game plan and so if
IID have been more involved in that part
I think I progressed quick as a passer
regardless if I was a a super athletic
talented quarterback in the west coast
system in 2004 I mean I made the Pro
Bowl I made it work we went to an NFC
Championship game imagine if I just put
a little bit more into it yeah you know
that's Super Bowl and Beyond so no
excuses I wish I could you know for
those reasons go back in time and and
change some of those things talking to
Michael Vic uh he's named to the uh
Madden 25th anniversary team do you have
a better understanding of who Dak
Prescott is right now or the Dallas
Cowboys are right
now well I feel like I I've seen Dak
enough to know that you know Dak
performs uh in big moments and he
understands you know what it takes to be
successful in this league you don't make
it to eight years um you know being
mediocre or being pedestrian I feel like
I know exactly what the Dallas Cowboys
are right now um when you look at them
uh offensively they're starting in jail
um getting better Mike McCarthy is the
play caller and I said I said this early
in the year you got to be patient with
situations like this because a lot of
people was quick to write off Dallas and
you know it wasn't playing competition
and you know I I don't listen to that
that's fluff to me because the National
Football League it's it's just so hard
to win on a on a week in week in and
week out basis um so you know the
offense is is jelling and you see
they're scoring points at a high rate
and then you got a defense that's uh you
know performing with you know high level
players and you know you got you know
guys stepping up and doing their job you
know all across the board front from
front to back so I feel like I know more
about the Cowboys I feel like they can
compete with Philadelphia and they can
compete with San FR now just got to keep
that ball rolling yeah but there's
certain teams though Mike that we go I
don't care what you do during the
regular season show me in January yeah
and Dallas is a team that we say show me
in January and I don't have any
confidence in them it's 30 years where
they they just somehow fail
Dan that's fair that's a fair assessment
to say um you know the regular
season can be somewhat irrelevant I
think the the regular season is just
it's practice reps you know it it's it's
competition that gets you ready for you
know the the postseason which is most
important and you know there are some
teams where we you say look you
know you you you've done a great job
throughout the okay now it's time to
take it one step further and being
honest Dallas they're one of those teams
and if you ask every single guy in the
locker room they'll probably tell you
the same exact things that we're talking
about now and
discussing the next step the next level
is where we got to excel playoffs and
Beyond and so you know they would be
doing themselves a disservice if they
didn't believe that wholeheartedly uh so
I expect them to take that next step
after watching them last night I'm
excited about them facing the 49ers or
facing Philadelphia because they'll
probably face the the 49ers first before
Philadelphia I think Philly get that
first round by so who knows how to be
configured but you know they have
opportunity okay be honest you're 43 I
think 43 43 would would you have been a
better quarterback the last three weeks
for the Jets than the situation that
they have right now yeah I'm being
honest I
mean there were times um over the last
year year and a half I was like man you
know what I'm gonna go down to this
local field put my ankle weights on and
put my weighted vest on like I used to
and and and get that mojo back and and
go help my squad out but then uh you
know that that's in the frontal low you
know but then you know back here I'm
like you know what it's best to just
play safe and you know uh you know you
can uh continue to commentate and and
give your analysis on what you thinking
H should happen but you know for the New
York Jets Aaron Rogers is coming back
you know it's reason to be optimistic in
the future I just hate to see us go out
there every week and um you know our
defense giving it everything they got
and those guys get tired man they
fatigue out and yeah they a lot of those
games are lost in the third and fourth
quarter and you can only give for so
much so yeah I wish they would have went
and grabbed the Josh dos or you know I
really think Carson Wentz would have
been able to give him some some instant
offense that we kind of missed the Bol
on some guys but hey that that's how it
goes how many starting quarterbacks can
outrun you right
now uh Lamar probably
Jaylen Kyler Patrick might give me a run
for my money Patrick got deceptive speed
you know um oh
things it's probably about six or seven
guys um that can outrun me okay in in
the league right now um you know I take
off running right now and if I don't
stretch you know which is you know
something I definitely didn't take
serious when I played uh I pul hamstring
really really quick I pulled my
hamstring doing run rich run two years
back to back and I had to go on a Hiatus
for that I was actually having a good
time doing it in preparation but about
five or six guys out there I'm probably
the sixth fastest quarterback in the
league right now it came too easy for
you oh it did um gift and the curse for
sure yeah uh you know being optimistic
every week you know it's like I know on
a on a consistent basis I'mma dominate
like as long as I was ready
mentally I could go Dominate and and so
you know sometimes I felt like I could
took that a step further um in terms of
preparation because I mean you can
prepare but you can never really be
overly prepared uh I think you know you
prepared and then then you
simplify uh and and that's just
communication with your coaches and and
you know them being on the same page as
offensive coordinat y understanding one
another it's like you know coach if all
else fails that's resort to this and if
all us feels I running two minute really
well and I seen that in piss with with
Ben rburg you know that was a great
experience um whenever things was a
little rocky uh you know it was a little
turbulent then then B just go no huddle
and just you know get get a rhythm going
and start calling the plays that he like
and that's professionalism at his finest
yeah yeah uh if I put you and Dion and
Bo Jackson in the 40 who wins it in your
Prime man those guys oh man I think Dion
wins okay I think I think Dion win man I
take nothing away from bo bo was
explosive and powerful and strong lower
body and I had the same and I but I did
run a 425 twice but Dion ran a 41 I
just I can't see that man I gotta you
know he's the goat for a reason you know
at his position and so I would I would
give the edge to Deion Sanders I wonder
about Tyreek Hill though like Tyreek
Hill's got different speed yeah so Dion
Sanders Tyreek Hill and deshan Jackson I
will pay to see that any day in their
Prime in their primes oh my God that
would have been amazing hey uh great to
talk to you as always and uh thanks for
joining us Michael good see you Dan
thanks for having Michael Vic uh Fox NFL
kickoff analyst four-time pro bowler and
recently named to Madden's 25th
anniversary team